there is always a new money making
opportunity that you wish you were
earlier in on we had Bitcoin 2012 crypto
and nft pumps 2021 ERC tax refunds and
now there's a brand new one pick doctors
launched a brand new program where
they're giving away over a billion
dollars and I haven't seen anybody
talking about it from Simply posting
extra tick tocks you can make anywhere
from a few extra thousand dollars a
month all the way up to Thirty to fifty
thousand dollars a month if you really
pop off I don't care about the algorithm
or retention on this video I just want
to hit those of you guys that are going
to take this information in and take
action on it so make sure you're
watching until the end and let's get
right into it before I get into what
exactly this program is and how you can
join let me show you some results of
other people just like you so you can
see that this works so this guy is
making six five two point five and two
thousand dollars on individual tick
tocks this guide made 730 off a tick
tock with one million views twelve
hundred dollars off a tick tock with two
million views thousand dollars on 878
000 views crazy all right so what
exactly is this program so first
starters this is different from tick
tock's Creator fun so I'm sure you've
heard how people are making money
on tick tock on the Creator fund people
would only make like a fraction of a
penny per thousand views so really
garbage now on The Tick Tock creativity
program a different thing for videos
over one minute long you're getting
around a dollar per thousand views AKA a
thousand dollars per million views which
is literally unheard of especially
considering how easy it is to go viral
on Tick Tock real quick even if you
don't know how to edit or you've never
even posted a tick tock don't worry make
sure you're watching till the end of the
video because I kept you guys into
consideration and kept info in this
video so that even you guys can succeed
so a dollar per thousand views that's
absolutely ridiculous why would Tick
Tock make this well there's a bunch of
different reasons now initially Tick
Tock was the main short form platform
there was no Instagram reels there was
no YouTube shorts no Snapchat Spotlight
even Twitter's coming up right now with
short from content there's nothing else
so now with all this different
competition coming up these platforms
are battling for users and keeping
people onto their platform YouTube
launched the shorts fund around six
months ago which drove a lot of people
off of tick tock onto there and so now
with Tick Tock rapidly using users
they're desperate to get a bunch of
people back with these companies
competing for people to stay on their
platforms and whatnot I cannot stress
the importance right now of getting into
Shore from content and staying
consistent with it as long as possible
because this isn't going anywhere this
is the best skill you could possibly
learn right now all right so before I
get into the strategies you're going to
use to attack this and make thousands of
dollars a month off of the program I
just want to go over a couple quick
requirements that you need a hit to
actually qualify for the program and
ways that you can get around them so for
the first requirement you need to be 18
years or older to get around this simple
you just have a parent or someone over
the age of 18 sign off on the account
and put their own information in so if
you're a minor have your parents have an
older brother any of them put their
information in and it'll be totally fine
for the second requirement you need to
be in the USA France or Brazil so to get
around this all you need to do is have
someone from one of these countries
start the account and put their
information in to actually qualify for
this program for the third requirement
you need to have 10 000 followers on The
Tick Tock account so I know that that
might sound a little bit daunting but
with the strategies that I'm going to
show you later in the video and with
really following the basic short form
principles 10 000 followers is actually
a lot easier to obtain than you thought
especially when you're starting off in a
new account because that is actually the
best time to go viral all of my most
viral videos have been on starting brand
new accounts from when I was in the nft
space we got I think 20 million views
across our first five videos on this
sunny fast brand I got 30 million views
within a week so stay tuned because I'm
going to get into that and then number
four is a hundred thousand views in the
last 30 days which is inevitable if
you're getting the 10 000 followers and
we're not even going for a hundred
thousand views we're going for millions
and making thousands a month off of this
you're probably wondering that's great
and all I want to get in the program but
how do I actually go about attacking
this well let's get into it number one
you want to pick a niche that you're
going to go into and then set up your
Tick Tock account you can either make
your own videos and film yourself or you
can go about clipping up other people's
videos and posting them on this account
so there's benefits and negatives to
both for filming your own videos and
making your own content the benefits are
you're building up your personal brand
brand so you're getting your face out
there some more you have more creative
freedom with actually how you want to
make the videos you're not relying on
someone else and then some of the
downsides are you might not be as
experienced on camera you don't actually
know what you're doing how to film the
videos and it might be more of a
creative process and a learning process
to actually get to that 10 000 follower
Mark initially and then there's the
other route where you're clipping up
other people's content that's previously
viral and then reposting it to tick tock
now to be honest this is the route that
I recommend that you go if you're
strictly looking to make money off of
this program the benefits are you know
that this content that's already been
posted is viral content so if you repost
it properly utilizing the tick tock
algorithm which I'm going to show you
how to do it's basically inevitable that
you go viral because it's already gone
viral on these other accounts another
thing is that you don't need to worry
about filming and going out this is a
lot more time effective because all you
need to do is download videos and clip
them up or with the strategy that I show
you later you're just downloading and
posting videos and to be honest there
aren't really many downsides of this
actually I would recommend going the
clipping up route if you don't have
experience with filming your own content
and you're really just looking to make
bread right away the third thing is your
first Focus needs to be just posting
viral videos until you hit that 10 000
follow Mark so you don't even want to
worry about the money coming in the
Creator fund none of that until you
hit the 10 000 follower Mark and you can
qualify for this program because that's
where the real money is going to be
getting made all right so to go viral
and actually get to that 10 000 follow
Mark I'll leave um a link to another
YouTube video on free Tick Tock tips
that I have that can help you out with
getting there but once you're actually
qualified in the program the strategy
that you're gonna do is you're gonna
post two one minute or longer videos per
day because like I said this creativity
program applies to videos over one
minute long and then you're also going
to post one normal length video per day
so 15 to 30 or 45 seconds just to
diversify it on the algorithm and it
keeps the account healthier for the one
minute videos there's a bunch of
different routes you can go you can post
full one minute long interactions of
clips from videos or if you're filming
yourself you can just edit a video
normally that comes out to being one
minute long you can do a one minute
compilation like one minute of speed
reacting to Chris from Mr Beast
one minute of Sunny's funniest clips
stuff like that one minute our
generation is doomed showing like public
interviews there's a million different
routes that you can go to be honest my
best recommendation would be you
actually scroll through Tick Tock for a
little bit and then for every video over
one minute long you bookmark it into a
folder that way you have a bunch of
examples of how other people are
utilizing this program because for the
most part every video you see that's
over a minute long on Tick Tock right
now that's intentional because these
people are getting paid out good all
right so after you're qualified and
you're posting the two minute or longer
videos per day and the one normal length
video per day what you're gonna do is
you're just gonna keep posting
consistently and watch the cash flowing
it's really as simple as that the
beautiful thing about this program is on
top of all the cash that you're going to
be making from it a dollar per thousand
views it's ridiculous now that
you built up a following there's also a
bunch of different monetization routes
you can go so now that you have a tick
tock account with followers brands are
going to be reaching out to you now you
can use that account to leverage it for
affiliate marketing so you can push
links on it you can push your own
company or if you're offering a program
or something you're starting an agency
you can utilize this new following to
push your own thing on top of the money
you're going to be making from the
program
so now here we are for a lot of you guys
that have never posted or edited tick
tocks or even if you have the problem in
your head of what do you post so I
actually came along and did the liberty
of solving this problem for you so what
I did is I created a ton of pre-edited
clips for you to use all completely
ready to be posted so even if you guys
have never posted a tick tock edited a
video or anything there's no excuse
because we have the videos made for you
so all you're doing is downloading and
posting them all of these clips are
totally free I'm not up charging I'm not
selling anything I'm literally just
dropping free value for you guys I'm
giving you a ridiculous opportunity to
make a bunch of money on Tick Tock right
now to get access to all these clips all
you need to do is join my free Discord
The Links at the top of the description
where you'll then be welcomed with a
tutorial video teaching you some more
Basics about The Tick Tock algorithm how
to download and post these videos and
where exactly to find these clips this
whole process of you downloading and
posting the clips with the strategies
that I'm going to be teaching you would
only take you Max an extra 15 minutes
per day there's no upfront cost so
there's really no downsides of doing it
I would definitely recommend you take a
stab at it I haven't done anything like
like this for the community in a really
long time and people have been lighting
up my DMs about new cash opportunities
with short form and other stuff and when
I saw this I just threw this quick
Discord together so that all of us can
eat and of course I'm incentivized too
with this stuff so I make previously
viral Clips because a lot of it is my
own content so I'm getting my brand out
there while at the same time you guys
are posting the videos and making cash
out of it so it's a win-win scenario for
both of us that's all I got join the
server for the free tutorial vid and
access to those pre-edited clips and if
you're interested in learning some more
tips about The Tick Tock algorithm
you'll definitely be interested in this
video right here so make sure you check
it out alright
see you guys